Galatians on your nomination how does it
feel to be activated awesome awesome
really really humbling and uplifting and
it's one of those kind of things that
you know people have instilled a
confidence or really have a faith in the
work that's being produced and potential
I guess that I happen that's kind of
been from very early from an early stage
and I think that's always been about for
me it's kind of like instilling
confidence in people give draw out their
abilities their voice and then
unfortunately and luckily I happened in
my respect and so many of the peers that
I'm surrounded by and showing their
nominations and so you know it's kind of
continuing that for anyone that has a
voice or wants to be heard and may or
may not get that opportunity for me
I focus on the company initially I think
that was the kind of that the for that
kind of pops in anyone's mom and kind of
about to kind of embark on such an
incredible journey was such an
incredible piece of work and story but
from the off in rehearsals it was about
the company is about who is surrounded
by is about what we are creating as a
company the pressure was in any in any
respect in the most positive way I took
the pressure off of myself what's the
most important thing in this story who
are the important people that can create
the story the company and so those are
the things that I focus on yeah I can
understand that for sure yeah when I
first said about a rap musical about
founding father you know some guy from
102 years ago yeah I mean if you make it
simple like that of course you can have
an incident reaction which is good but
as is testament to the work as you can
see what Lindholm most creative genius
and not only in just the way he's
managed to use language to tell a story
but also the themes the the story itself
what is kind of pulled on to make that
and allow us to see the relevance of
that and the poignancy of that and then
that's continued and you know hopefully
maybe one day that that poignancy in
terms of in terms of immigration in
terms of being others won't be the case
and will think that was one that helped
change the narrative for our society I
think it has I think has that and other
shows of doing that one guy who I think
spoken to a Rennes day he's a part of
that a part of telling different stories
about opening and narrative we're all a
part of one story but there's many
different stories and voices to be heard
within that it's about making sure that
everyone is heard and that in politics
is democracy but in life that's just
called a community that's put together
so that's yeah hundred Commons devenir
by that because what it's shown is that
you can have a diverse show at the
highest level